(audience applauds)
- They're very excited.
I gotta be honest.
You walked out and I was like
you look like a bronze goddess.
(Hailey laughs)
Like I was like "What?"
(audience applauds)
Yeah, you should have a skincare line.
Your skin looks like amazing.
Anyway, I'll get to it, anyway.
How are you?
- I'm good, thank you.
- You're good.
How are you?
- I know there was like a health scare.
You're good though, right?
- Yes. There was a health scare.
I'm totally okay now.
I'm doing much better.
I'm doing completely fine.
- And it was something random, right?
That you'd never heard of that.
I think that's,
it's not cool that it's happening to you,
but I think that it's cool
that you're putting a spotlight on it
for people that maybe
didn't have the spotlight.
- Yeah.
It was something that
honestly, I was born with.
I was born with a heart defect.
It's called a PFO.
I won't try to butcher
the actual name of it,
but basically I was born with a hole
in my heart and it never closed, and...
- [Kelly] Wow.
- I didn't know.
Apparently it's very, very common.
A lot of people have
it and they don't know.
And it was just kind of
like this perfect storm
of things that led to me
having a small blood clot
which was really scary and really crazy.
And I had something called a TIA,
which is like a mini stroke.
- Geez.
- Yeah.
- And you're so young,
but it's like it's horrible
that it happened to you,
but it's nice that you're putting
awareness on it just for people...
- Yeah.
- 'Cause can you get like a
scan to check that, to see?
'Cause I've had a heart scan.
I don't know if they could
tell me if there's a hole.
- You can, there's a special type
of testing you can do for it.
And I never knew any of this before.
I thought I was...
- When you're young, like why?
- 25 and healthy.
- Yeah. Like I wouldn't have, yeah.
- I had no idea, but it's,
it's been a big learning experience.
I, you know, I made a video about it.
I talked about everything.
- Yeah.
- And hopefully it can,
it can help someone going
through the same thing, so.
- Absolutely. And just
something to be aware of.
'Cause I'd never heard of that.
- Yeah.
- Well what are your summer plans?
What are you gonna do?
- Summer plans?
Honestly, I think we're just gonna...
- Chill?
- Chill.
Travel a little bit.
- Yeah.
It's cool that you can travel now.
- Yeah. It's really nice
to be able to travel now.
I feel like I'm such a planner,
but I also try not to plan
like too far in advance,
because I never even know what
I'm actually doing next week.
- Yes.
- But I definitely just wanna spend like,
time with friends, time with family.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Be outside, be in nature.
- Just rest, honestly.
- I love that. Resting is so important.
I shall do that.
- Yeah.
This summer.
- [Hailey] Please do.
- I've I have heard it spoken
of, so I'm going to do it.
So I hear that you love like diners,
and like drive-ins, like dive bars,
like, is this true?
- Okay. So what's true,
is that I love the show
"Diners, Drive-ins And Dives."
- Oh.
- The Guy Fieri show.
- Wait. So I love drive-ins,
and I love dive bars.
I think they're the,
sometimes it's like the best,
not for you, but it's the best food.
- The best food.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
So I love that show because I just am
obsessed with Guy Fieri,
- Yeah.
and I'm obsessed with the show.
(audience applauds)
- And yeah, let's give it up
for Guy Fieri for one second.
But I love it because
we love to like road trip and like,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My husband's on tour right now.
So we're in a lot of different new places,
a constant road trip.
(audience cheers)
- But do you see, you're
probably lucky though because,
because people think like
we get to go on tour, right?
- Right.
- But you're usually seeing
the hotel room and the airport.
You know, you don't really
get to, do you venture out?
Do you get to do that?
- It depends on how much time
we're spending in that one place.
It is actually, usually really, In-N-Out,
But what I do is I go on the
Diners, Drive-ins, and
ooh that's a difficult...
- Yeah, it's a tough one.
- "Diners, Drive-Ins, And Dives" website
and I look at if there's anything
in the city that we're in
and I order takeout from the place.
- This is my vibe.
- So I can try it.
- Yeah. I love that.
You come from a pretty famous family,
but you say you grew up pretty normal.
So what is that like?
What was growing up,
because your family's not,
your family's really famous.
- Yeah.
- I don't know if you know.
Yeah.
- I say that because I feel
like I look back on my childhood
and, and maybe it's because to me,
like my family was always normal to me.
I didn't see it any different
other than the fact that like,
- Yeah.
- Sometimes when we would
go places like my dad
would get recognized, my
uncles would get recognized,
and like I think I just grew up,
for me that being normal.
But we, my sister and I,
and my parents, we grew up
in a small suburb of New York city.
And I just felt like,
that it was just very normal to me.
Like small town, ballet class every day.
And it wasn't, you know, like growing up
in maybe LA or like just
around the industry very much.
- That's really cool that
your parents did that for you.
I always, like, I always
worry with my kids
just being in the, I'm in
the public eye, they stop
and my kids are like, "Why
are people talking to you?"
- Right.
- Like, and it's like, I'm like,
"Oh, it's just everybody
knows everybody. It's fine."
- Look, it's LA.
- Yeah. It's just, it's 'cause
it's one of those things you don't
want to affect your children.
So you just seem very grounded.
So that's nice.
And you have a very strong faith, right?
- Yeah.
- Is that like, why was
that so important for you?
Have you been like that
since you were a kid?
- Yeah. I mean, I grew
up being raised that way.
I grew up being raised in the church.
And I think that's
something that's always been
very important to me, and
something that has stuck with me
since I was a kid, and will
continue to be something,
that is the number one thing for me.
- That's really cool.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna come back to your glowing,
beautiful bronzey skin, 'cause
you have a skincare line.
(audience cheers)
Which I think is very
organic for you to do.
- Yes.
- So what made you want to do this?
Like were you trying things
you just didn't like them?
- Sort of, but kind of, not necessarily.
I've always been really
passionate about skincare.
I've always loved it.
- It's worked out.
- It's always been something
I've honestly been obsessed with.
And I feel like growing up,
my grandmother was really
obsessed with skincare.
My mom was really into skincare.
So I felt like I just
learned a lot from them.
And over the last like eight
years of just traveling
and working, I've had the
privilege of being able to work
with all these different,
amazing makeup artists,
and facialists, and aestheticians,
and so many amazing people,
and just absorbing information.
And getting to know
like what they're into,
what products they like.
And it's really helped me develop
what my beauty philosophy is.
- Yeah.
- And you know, we started
the process of Rhode
two and a half years ago.
And basically for me, what
happened during the pandemic,
I felt like I had all this extra time.
We were in lockdown and I already knew
what I really liked in skincare,
and most of what I didn't like,
but I was like let me just start
from zero and let me try everything.
Let me just dive into every product.
Let me see...
- How'd that work out?
I have such sensitive skin.
I would break out it.
- Yeah, same.
It wasn't great for me at times.
Yeah. But it was actually a good lesson
for me to learn, like what
I would stay away from,
and what I gravitated towards.
So through all this research,
through all this time
spent trying different things,
reading about different ingredients.
I really landed on all the stuff that
I loved and...
- It worked for you.
- Yeah. That worked for me.
And so our ethos basically at Rhode
is "One of everything really good."
And that's a philosophy
that I don't only have
in beauty and skin care,
but in also in like curating my wardrobe.
So basically like that one
really good pair of jeans
that you're always going
back to and reaching for,
that one really good jacket that you just
like are always going back to.
Same thing for skincare.
That one really good moisturizer
that you're always going back to,
that one like trusty lip balm
that you're always going back to.
So that is our philosophy at Rhode,
and that's what we're doing.
- And Rhode is your middle name?
- Yeah, Rhode is my middle name.
And it's a family name and...
- What a cool name.
- Yeah. I think so.
I really like it.
I always had a dream of
having a brand that was named
after Rhode because
it's also a family name.
It's my mom's middle name too so...
- Yeah. I love it.
- That's how we landed on that, yeah.
- Well I think that
this is super important.
What are the products?
Like what did you start with?
- So the first products
we're launching with,
it's only three products.
They're completely focused on hydration.
I have like you sensitive
skin, very dry skin.
I move around a lot.
I travel a lot.
We get our make-up done all the time.
All these things contribute
to just like dehydrated skin.
And I really believe that no matter what
your skin type is hydration is important.
And it's just about finding the right
source of hydration for you.
- Yeah.
- So we have our our moisturizer,
it's called the barrier restore cream.
It's just this really like
delicious, yummy moisturizer.
The peptide
- I love when my skin feels like that.
- Right?
The peptide glazing fluid,
which is our gel serum,
and the peptide lip treatment,
which is our yummy...
- Now I never used to, but now to get the
lipstick, we don't have
to put this on air,
but now they do the
ones that stay forever.
So like I find my lips peeling more often,
because they do the
ones that stay forever,
and then they seal it in.
So it lasts the whole day.
- Yeah.
- But then at the end of
the night, you're like,
you're like trying to get it off.
And then I have like weird lips.
So that's nice.
- I can never stay, like my
biggest pet peeve is dry...
cracky,
- Cracky gross, yeah.
- Flaky lips. So I like...
- No one wants to kiss that.
- Slather stuff on at night.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Not attractive.
- No, no, no no.
- It's not attractive.
- We're not doing dry lips over here.
- Yeah. So you have a beauty
thing that I think is funny.
It's something like a
glazed donut or something.
You like a glazed, what is it called you?
- I like looking like a glazed
donut before I go to bed.
- And I like eating a glazed donut.
- And I also like eating glazed donuts,
because who doesn't love a great donut.
- So you just love it to look,
I like that when I'm on like vacation
I have time and I'm just sitting in it.
- Yeah. And I feel like the
glazed donut thing, it's not
something I came up with.
It's not something I like,
- I never heard of that.
- I invented at all.
I feel like it is something
that's talked about a lot
in like the skin world and like
the skin-fluence world that
people love this look of...
- Was this the goal, to
get glazed donut look?
- I think for me, I, if
I'm going to bed at night,
I wanna make sure I
have that like slathered
and lathered glazed donut look.
- Yeah. Well now I'm just hungry, Hailey,
and I'm trying not to eat sugar,
but it's great to see you.
Thank you...
- Thank you.
- So much for being here.
Rhode Skincare is available now online.
Y'all gotta check it out,
if you wanna look like a glazed donut.